the health secretary matt hancock is
with us now hello to you mr hancock
we're always uh pleased when you can
spend the time how are you talk to us
want to talk to you about that
and i'm okay thank you i've had my flu
jab and i feel okay about it
so fingers crossed it's going to be fine
and hopefully many people will be able
to benefit from that this year as well
thanks to
your government want to talk about your
brief shortly but first
you know the elephant in the room we
have to deal with that if you could be
as succinct as possible with your
answers and then we can move on
to your brief uh the prime ministerial
code in his very own words
he says there must be no bullying and no
harassment why is pretty patel still in
a job this morning
well there is a report that hasn't been
published
so none of us have uh seen it but all i
could tell you is that
uh when uh in my extensive dealings with
pretty patel she's been nothing
but uh courteous and kind she's
worked hard and is working hard to
deliver on
on on the commitments on which we were
elected to
have twenty thousand more police there's
uh there's that was our commitment we've
already
she's already delivered more than five
thousand extra
police okay and um yeah and that's what
she's been getting on with
let's let's stay on point should we if
we may she may be polite to you because
you are
a peer if not a senior to her it's those
below her
that she appears to be bullying uh one
of them came out the senior civil
servant sir philip
rutnam saying this is what she's up to
another one had worked all night
she according to the report was so so
so unpleasant to her that this younger
person
collapsed
well you say according to the report but
nobody's seen the report and it hasn't
been published
so obviously i can't comment on that
what i can tell you is my
my what i know about pretty and and i
know that she's
she's incredibly courteous
have you bullied anyone
well i absolutely hope not and you know
the way that i
try to uh to bring take the team forward
is
by being positive and encouraging but
you know
sure it's it's what matters is what you
what you can deliver for the people who
elected us and
as i say you know the uh pretty has been
delivering uh an increase in the number
of police
in order to keep people safe uh and um
let's stay on point health secretary and
and
well if we may how would you know yeah
we know you've told us about the
training we know what her job is about
i'm talking about her bullying people
and whether or not she has done that
you i asked you whether you had bullied
anyone you said you certainly hoped not
my point is perhaps it was unintentional
because
that's uh what we're hearing uh from the
home office and from number 10 today
if she bullied anybody perhaps it was
unintentional
even if it was unintentional bullying is
still bullying isn't it
well i i just i we i haven't seen this
report unfortunately uh uh which means i
can't
go and go into any more detail because
i i haven't been in i haven't i haven't
seen the report
uh i but i do know what
uh my experience of working closely with
the home secretary is
and the experience that that i've always
had
working with her has been that she's
nothing but
courteous in getting the job done and
that's so that's what i can report to
you
okay well none of us have seen the uh
report in full because the prime
minister is uh refusing
to publish the full cabinet office
investigation at this stage maybe that
will change let me try once more if
in the fullness of time we discover that
the report says that she did
bully somebody orbit or several people
all be unintentional
what should happen
well that's a matter for the prime
minister and not for me i'm dealing with
a global pandemic and i'll leave that
one to the prime minister
what do you think all of the available
evidence
[Applause]
okay um okay well it i'm sure my viewers
will will come to their own conclusions
this morning as to whether or not you
want to condemn somebody who
who potentially uh bullied someone to
the extent where they collapsed after
working overnight
let's talk about the public sector pay
freeze why um
is there a public sector pay freeze uh
not including thankfully nhs workers
um when people have worked
so hard like the armed services like the
fire service like
other frontline workers during this
pandemic
well again there's speculation that i've
seen in the newspapers but
there's no announcements made on this
subject and it's very much a matter for
the chancellor
exchequer given uh
what he needs to do on the economic
front
what i can tell you is that within my
area
within the nhs people have worked
incredibly hard and
i'm i i value and the whole country
values the work that they do enormously
not just in tackling this pandemic but
also in looking after people
all of the time making sure that making
sure that that
there is always that support there for
you if you need it in the nhs
are you getting a pay rise this year
well as i say these questions are a
matter for the chancellor he's setting
out his spending review
uh next week are you getting very
difficult circumstances
well i can't answer that question uh
what i can tell you is that the
chancellor is setting out his spending
review
next week and um
and i'm afraid that on questions like
these there's a load of speculation in
the papers i can see that
but i don't know the answer to the
question and um
we'll just have to wait to hear what he
says
i think i know the answer to the
question i think you're getting 3 360
pounds that's certainly
the pay rise proposed for mps you
already earned more than a hundred
thousand
we're expecting public sector workers to
have their pay frozen how is that fair
well i'm i'm afraid that's just not
that's just not right
we don't know what the circumstances
will be um
the pay of mps is set independently i
don't have a say over it that's quite
right i've never voted for
uh on matters of pay of mps and i'm
really glad that that was
sorted out before i entered parliament
because i think that it's fair that it's
set uh it's set independently
but these are matters that need to be
properly discussed when the details can
be set out
what i what i do know is that the
pandemic has had a
very serious impact on people's health
but also on the economy
we all know that and we can all see it
and it's a very difficult set of
circumstances
i understand that and that's obviously
why potentially there'll be a public
sector pay freeze my question is do you
think it's fair
that if there is a public sector pay
freeze mps still get a pay rise
well i can't get into it i'm afraid kay
i'm here to talk about the
uh this rollout of the of the flu jab
i i'd love to answer the question in
more detail and
talk about let's talk about it let's
talk about it as
and when any formal announcements have
been made but i don't know what those
formal announcements will be
and we have to wait for the chancellor
to set out the details i'm i'm terribly
sorry i can't
be more helpful than that okay you're a
cabinet secretary and so you have
collective responsibility so you know
you should be able to tell us
uh in a bit more detail but okay i hear
what you say uh come back and talk to us
when you have more information tell me
about the vaccination
rollout then can we really vaccinate a
million brits a day that sounds amazing
and fantastic if we can
well the the nhs has long experience of
these mass vaccination programs
the flu jab is a case in point normally
15 million people a year
are vaccinated with flu this year it
will be 30 million
it's the biggest in history as of
this morning we are making clear that
anybody over 50
can get a free flu jab and i urge
everybody over 50 to come forward
and that is being delivered by the nhs
and of course we hope we hope that we'll
also have a covert vaccination program
alongside that and the arrangements are
being put in place for the nhs
to deliver that at scale it'll be a
huge effort and i know that the nhs is
up to it
so we could get a vaccination for the
flu and covid potentially at the same
time is that what you're saying that's
amazing
what well they're within a matter of
weeks
uh they uh there is um making sure that
uh your you can have uh both of them
they might not have
might not be able to take them on the
same day but we
absolutely have got plans for these two
huge vaccination programs
uh to go on in parallel you know we were
just talking about how much
nhs staff have worked through this
crisis and
you know this is another example of the
work that they've got to do to
you know to keep us safe obviously no
covert vaccination has been signed off
yet but there are
encouraging signs of hope and
we heard again this week good news on
the astrazeneca
vaccine and and on the fisa vaccine as
well the two
early vaccines so the nhs is
getting those plans in place to be able
to run
a mass covert vaccination program
alongside
the biggest flu vaccination program in
history so
you know it's a it's a big task but the
nhs is up to it
so we're only weeks away from a mass
vaccination
for covid and certainly before christmas
is the hope
that's the hope nothing's guaranteed yet
actually the big you know the big
numbers in terms of if
it comes through are more likely to be
in the new year
rather than before christmas um
because we're absolutely determined that
any vaccination program will be
safe and but nevertheless
uh this is you know we have had really
encouraging news over the last two weeks
on the
main uh vaccinations in the meantime
it's so important that people keep
following those rules and the social
distancing rules
you know there are there are encouraging
signs that the number of cases
is starting to flatten and that the
lockdown that we brought in earlier this
month
is working but in the meantime
everybody's got to keep following the
rules however
we've all been looking for the way out
the exit strategy the
the way out of this the difficult
circumstances that this pandemic has
has necessitated and with the
the increasingly encouraging news on the
vaccine
we can start to see that but we're not
there yet
okay in the meantime uk wide christmas
rules for all
four nations what's that going to look
like
well again on this we don't know yet you
know i
i know how much how important christmas
is it's important to my family it's
important to
people right across the country we want
to have a set of rules if at all
possible that's uk wide not least
because so many people travel
between different parts of the uk and so
we're working with the devolved
authorities to try to get an agreed set
of
rules for christmas it it of course
won't be like a normal christmas
there will have to be rules in place but
we hope that they'll allow for a bit
more of that normal christmas that
people
really look forward to
give me an idea what that might look
like what what are you planning for
christmas at the moment
well at the moment i'm i'm planning a
small family
christmas and my current plans are of
course within the existing
rules uh because um because we haven't
made any further
decisions yet uh and i'm sure
everybody's
you know looking forward to you know
with hope
that we can see our loved ones and we
want to have a set of rules that
allow for allow for something a bit more
like normal allow people to
uh to see some of their loved ones but
still keep
the virus under control because you know
we're having to take these extraordinary
measures to keep the virus under control
and the uh but at the same time i think
everybody recognizes
uh that christmas really is a very
special day
yeah um and a quick thought before i let
you go um on
uh suggestions that dolly parton and the
fact that she's invested
uh a million dollars in uh vaccination
uh
research means that it's been available
much quicker
than normal um i had alex sharma on the
show
a couple of days ago and he's promised
to do
uh kenny rogers duet with me with
islands in the stream
um if we do get it before christmas this
vaccine it's got to be worth it just for
that hasn't it health secretary
there's many many reasons i want a
covered vaccine before christmas and to
watch you and alok sharma sing dolly
parton is just one more
there we go but in all seriousness just
before i let you go i just want to press
you once more
uh on uh prissy patel you said that you
know she's only
ever been courteous to you of course
bullies never pick on people their own
size
if it's proven that she is a bully what
should happen
thank you for asking again uh that's a
matter for the prime minister
okay it's good to talk to you as always
thank you health secretary